[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is an
american author michael malus welcome to
trigonometry thank you so much i'm very
excited it's great to have you on the
show listen for anyone who's not
familiar with you uh as with all our
guests just tell everybody a little bit
about who you are how are you where you
are what has been the journey through
life that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us oh i got to do the work
absolutely this is what is this this is
how this show works we do [ __ ] all just
get you to talk i get i win some
contests at burger king and now i gotta
go on the show and just do all the
talking uh i i this is always kind of
odd um i guess i was i um
i'm the author of dear reader the
unauthorized autobiography of kim
jong-il which is a book about north
korea and and pretty much everything you
need to know about that awful awful
place the book after that was called the
new right which is a look at the um
kind of alternative right wing
including the alt-right here in the
states that culminated in the trump
victory and my most recent book which is
i think where we're here is the
anarchist handbook which is
anarchist-handbook.com which is a
compilation that i've written
or compiled to be more precise when
people kept asking about anarchism means
of all the prominent anarchist authors
in the last you know a couple hundred
years uh in one handy package um well
you say the last book is why you're here
and certainly the case but also your
previous book as well then you write
something uh that will incorporate into
what we talk about uh very much in the
spirit of getting you to do the work one
of the things we kind of char on on our
show is the political landscape and that
how that's been evolving over the last
many years uh and there's so many
aspects of that we could get into but
let me ask you a very broad-based
question which is what is happening in
the west particularly in anglosphere in
your opinion what do you think are the
kind of focus points that we should look
at
um i don't know about should but i i
mean there's lots of things that are
happening that i think are historically
unprecedented um
i can't speak that well to british
politics although i follow it uh fairly
closely
what happens here but we import your
[ __ ] five years later or now two years
later so you gotta
you have it backwards we import your
[ __ ] thatcher led to reagan the fabian
society led to the uh council of uh was
what is it called the cea whatever it is
here so
britain thatcher talked about this her
books right behind me that you guys are
kind of the petri dish and then american
ideas follow suit so i think it's
actually brexit press age trump
um you know those are similar phenomenon
in the states i think we are at a kind
of and this is always the case in
politics kind of an inflection point
because for the last four years so much
of the sound and fury was about trump
and reacting to him or supporting him
and you know whatever his latest outrage
of the day happened to be whether
synthetic or feigned
now that he has left
the oval office and these lockdowns are
kind of
receding into the background i think
among um
thought leaders particularly you know
the corporate press there seems to be a
little bit of confusion as to who the
latest boogeyman is going to be uh who
are they going to rile up the masses
against and and create as the villain of
our time uh they tried to do tucker
carlson to some extent matt gates who's
a congressman from florida um and and
you know what happened on january 6 but
nothing seems to be sticking there
doesn't seem to be the outrage and the
frothing of the mouth which was so
entertaining to watch over the last four
years what we are seeing i think and
which i'm doing my best in my very
limited power to escalate
is an increasing division
in american politics and an increasing
inability of different political world
views to have any kind of conversation
at all and i think the further that
happens and i think it's increasing
uh at a fairly strong pace uh the better
it's going to be for everyone involved
do you think part of the problem michael
is that we now conflate politics and
morality so for instance people on the
left think people are not only wrong
about their political opinions but
they're also evil
etc etc
uh i'm from the iran school so i
don't understand how one can separate
those two things i think the moral and
the political are
by and large synonymous i i don't really
understand the claim that one can make
politics without you know moral basis
for it and i think what we're seeing in
jonathan height covers this very well in
his book the righteous mind there seems
to be a um
sort of this crusade mindset uh which i
think is absolutely wonderful among
people who are you know in a broad sense
of the left and a broad sense of the
right which leaves very little room for
moderates which is something i'm very
pleased with you know having an enormous
amount of contempt for people who
describe themselves as moderates so
having that kind of
us versus them mindset uh you know as an
anarchist is a very useful tool towards
breaking down political discourse which
inevitably ends up in loss of freedom
from one group or another well it's
actually great that you bring up
moderates and why you you despise them
francis and i probably consider
ourselves moderates what's wrong with
being moderate
um
someone who has no principles in theory
is going to be a very little use in
terms of putting forth their ideas in
practice in a political sense especially
when you're dealing with an enemy class
which is inherently malevolent and if
they had their druthers would engage in
just the worst kind of atrocities so to
stand up against that and to say well we
need to hear both sides as a position i
don't find to be tenable um i suppose
it's a question of definition
and maybe moderate isn't the word i
certainly think of myself more as a
centrist and what i mean by that is i
have very strongly held views and
principles that are right of center and
equally strong and and uh
strongly held principles that are left
of center but it's not an absence of
principle it's just my principles don't
tend to match neatly onto the right or
to the left
do you see what i'm saying yeah but that
just kind of makes you a bit of a
you know a gadfly doesn't mean you're in
the center i mean so i i don't i i think
that word
is uh
is just to me just noxious uh because it
just speaks to people who like describe
themselves as kind of agnostic because
they just don't want to address the
issue at all um so i i i don't what do
you see as the efficacy of uh describing
yourself with that label
yeah
your criticism is valid in that i am not
satisfied with the label i just i know
that politically i don't align with
either left or right and there doesn't
seem to be another pigeon hole for me
well uh
i can resolve that one in one question
do you think some people are better than
others
no
well better wait hold on that's a it's a
do you mean more valuable or do you mean
superior in one way or another do you
think some people are better than others
at some things yeah okay so you're on
the right if you're on the right and
answer yes and if you're on the left you
have to give a speech so that that is a
litmus test that people can use to
figure out if there's
francis he claims to be the old school
left wing can you can you debunk him
live on that many people who are old
school left-wing would be regarded as
the right there's this this very um
silly idea which i'm positive you two
don't ascribe to which regard right and
conservative and republican and tori as
synonymous you know as as people who
understand world politics to claim these
three these terms are interchangeable is
very bizarre but it's a very useful for
corporate media because if there's two
choices and right equals republican or
tory in your case and left equals labor
a democrat and i dismiss one of the two
teams then in a binary fashion therefore
i've proven the other one and things get
very simple uh right and left are just
complicated nuanced positions and they
depend on what the axis happens to be
but this kind of
attempt and this is also done in
political parties as well to reduce it
to you know i'm right therefore i'm for
boris johnson who is identical somehow
to theresa may is
re or as if cirque
and jeremy corbyn are the same
phenomenon either it's a very or tony
blair it's a very um
wacky uh way of systemization
and if it is a very wacky way of
systemization doesn't that therefore
mean that our political systems are not
are no longer fit for purpose because
they don't represent us adequately
they've never been fit for purpose
that's the basic anarchist critique that
the idea of representation is inherently
not just false but nonsensical
what does that mean elaborate on that a
little bit meaning that
if i go to the supermarket you know i
have infinite choices of what to buy to
drink breads
so on and so forth but that i have to
pick someone who's going to speak for me
both for foreign policy and for you know
health care and for taxation
and i don't get to pick the person i
want because a lot of my neighbors think
otherwise
this is a very
bizarre claim that if i vote for
tony blair and i get theresa may then
theresa may represents me i want tony
blair to represent me and obviously they
didn't run against each other so that
whole basis which were all um
many people seem to accept would only be
regarded even as a hypothesis if we've
been trained to believe this since birth
in government schools if someone came to
you as an adult and say if you vote for
person a but a lot of people vote for
person b person b represents you it
wouldn't even make sense as a hypothesis
like what are you even talking about
this person represents me this is my
lawyer this is my accountant this is my
doctor but when it comes to politics
it's a popularity contest that i really
don't have a choice about it it boggles
the mind
and michael you make that point and it
is a perfectly valid one so what is the
alternative
freedom but what does that mean
it means that if you want someone to be
your doctor this is who you have as your
doctor and it is what you want is your
lawyer this is your lawyer you can fire
them at any time and anything that is
historically done through the state uh
can either be done voluntarily or
shouldn't be done at all
so you're leading us nicely down the
garden path of the argument you make in
your latest book uh i guess the question
most people would be asking at this
point well
there's two ways i can ask a stupid
question which is what most people would
ask which is let's do it come on
[Laughter]
okay speak to the masses
let's do it's not even about the masses
actually i think the masters actually
wouldn't ask this question but a
political journalist might
which is oh you think there should be no
state
and that's a very simple way of asking
it so let's do that first
yes
and what would be there in its place
uh uh
what would be what happens when you
i'm going to apologize to you guys over
across the pond what happened when we
abolish king george who's going to be
the king uh what happens if you leave
the catholic church who's going to be
the pope so this concept that you need
to have some kind of political
figurehead to represent you
and this person is irreplaceable is is
no but those two things well not those
two things but king george was replaced
with an alternative power structure one
that you guys in america are still
fighting to shape exactly as you want
uh he he was actually replaced with the
power structure that was itself replaced
in a coup uh in philadelphia the
constitutional convention where that it
was a conspiracy where everyone swore
themselves to secrecy lock the door and
basically overthrew the government
through largely peaceful means the
replacement for any um
organization would be you know infinite
people uh providing solutions and
everyone else in a position to either uh
use their services or not but or this
applies to security this applies to
healthcare this applies to education uh
no matter what field you're thinking
about we you want more freedom more
choices which means more peace and more
um
calm
happy neighborhoods
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
bridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anton has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge is such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
okay so let me ask this slightly more
intelligent question which is yeah i
enjoyed your conversation with jordan
peterson and we we had jordan on the
show a number of times the jor the
petersonian question here would be well
human beings like many animals or almost
all animals require live in hierarchy
and they're unable to exist outside of
one so 100
so what would
hypothetically what would happen if you
get rid of the power structures that
exist there's now another power
structure would emerge
and human history would tend to suggest
that the people who are most vicious
most brutal most well-armed etc in that
power structure would initially take
over and then that would probably settle
down into something a little bit more
peaceful is that are you not just
opening up the door to like a violent
struggle between small groups
essentially if you do that well no
you're describing is the status quo so
in politics the most vicious sociopaths
are the ones who end up getting at the
top what you would have in a
decentralized system is when you have
like for example i don't know how it
works over in britain but let's talk
about here in the states and the police
right if you have a police officer who
engages in ways that is murder or just
completely outrageous i'm not talking
about a racial element there's things
you can go on youtube there's just
infinite cases of the police acting in
ways that are just completely egregious
there's having a government monopoly on
this as having a government monopoly on
anything means there's no accountability
uh there's no space to really make
things better whereas if i have an issue
with let's suppose harrods right and i
want to return a sweater harrod's policy
is very clear we have a dispute i want
to return the sweater they won't take
the sweater or they will it's resolved
quickly and immediately if harrods is i
go into harrods and i get beaten or
tased for whatever reason very quickly i
can go on social media and this becomes
a huge scandal even if i was in the
wrong that's what's amazing thanks to
things like publicity and and dynamic
communication uh stories blown complete
blown out proportion and out of context
but the the issue is very quickly the
issue needs to be addressed whereas if
you look there's a case here in the
states this young man named duncan lamp
and they had a no knock warrant uh on
him i don't know if you guys have that
over there you probably might not we're
basically the
even the the line i always had is even
stalin had the courtesy to knock so they
break down your door and it was i think
three in the morning he was in bed with
his pregnant girlfriend uh they murdered
him
through the window and they dragged her
through the broken glass
they won't release the body cam footage
and none of the police are having any
consequences at the very least if you
had choices in security there would be
some there would be consequences for the
perpetrator and you wouldn't have the
ability to choose another agency as the
one providing the security for you and
there would be immediate huge social
media and
probably corporate media reactions to
this consequence as it is
having a government monopoly and having
the corporate media very much in bed
with them which i certainly have in the
uk here in the states there are no
consequences for everyone and everything
is swept under the rug so that is one
example of how if you did not have a
government monopoly and had competition
and choice uh there would be more
accountability and less murder by the
state okay michael so i'm going to push
back with you so let's say that works on
a national level what about a global
level you're going to have countries
like china you're going to have you know
countries like russia totalitarian
regimes are interested in power land
grabs etc etc doesn't it leave you open
and vulnerable to these types of nations
who's why aren't we invading canada why
aren't you guys invading iceland doesn't
have a military why hasn't britain
conquered it
and you we're too incompetent well
actually i would argue that because they
live under the american umbrella of
protection like right of the west sure
so the the point is there's just because
governments exist on earth does not mean
anarchism is not tenable i'm not arguing
at all that for this perspective to work
it has to work globally china will still
exist but i don't understand a mechanism
if say uh um scotland right if scotland
seceded from the uk and you know they
just did not have a government it became
a stateless society
how is china going to be invading them
or any other nefarious nation other than
britain itself but you are not
advocating this for scotland you are
advocating it for america
i think it would be easier to invade
scotland than to invade an anarchist
america don't you
um
by the way
i'm not even advocating this for america
i'm just advocating this for whoever
wants it and if it has to be a small
isle of wight or whatever that's
perfectly fine with me there's i i'm not
someone who thinks uh and you know it
historically
and this is something the west needs to
appreciate if you read comic books if
you read sci-fi movies the guys who want
to conquer the world are the bad guys so
i'm in no cl case advocating that this
has to work and it has to work on a
global scale it is my view that if this
does work it'll certainly attract people
towards that area and if it doesn't work
okay that area is a disaster in neither
case is there a claim that this is
something that needs to happen or should
happen on a global scale
and you we've been touching actually on
authoritarianism this is something that
i really wanted to speak to you about
michael
uh so you've got your roots in the in
the ussr soviet union you went to
america i believe at the age of two
years old
constantine is from the ussr my mother's
venezuelan we've all experienced
different forms of authoritarianism one
of the things that i found really
shocking in the uk i don't know as much
as in america is just how willing people
in this country were to
submit to an authoritarian
let's call it what it was an
authoritarian rule but not only that
also to snitch on their neighbors
also to be to have you know to feel this
sense of paranoia and everything they
did and everything they said
and the way we descended into that just
seemed to happen practically overnight
did that surprise you
uh it surprised me to the extent but
it's useful information uh h.l menken
who i'm sure many of your listeners are
familiar with was a great newspaper man
of the early 20th century and he had a
quote which i've been using i think on a
daily basis in the last few months which
is the average man does not want to be
free he merely wants to be safe
and i do think that's the case i think
if i'm a average person and i really
don't want to stick my neck out and i
want to be someone in a school of fish
that's not a bad strategy for me uh you
know i'm going to you know put food in
the table i'm going to have some modicum
of happiness people like to claim that
we're living in 1984 but i think aldous
huxley's brave new world is a lot closer
to the reality instead of that hard
authoritarianism of you know the
stalinist 1984 you have the soft
corporate authoritarianism of
come to the office do your job come home
you can watch crap television eat crap
food but you're never going to have to
be worried that you're going to have to
think or that anyone is going to
threaten you given that that's the case
of the mindset of the typical human
being
democracy on its face is something i do
not therefore find palatable it is i
have a different preference their
preference is for safety over freedom
that's fine i'm not interested in
changing their mind what i am interested
in is creating mechanisms to make sure
they are not in a position to use their
fear of autonomy to have restrictions on
my freedom and now how that would work
out is obviously a very complicated long
conversation my gut tells me technology
is the best way to make this happen but
i agree with you but the other thing
that i think is of interest that people
need to appreciate is what the lockdowns
gave is a position for lowest status
people to have ways to increase their
status and to assert dominance over
others because i saw this on the subway
i i was
i would had my podcast so i didn't i
could actually go into the studio
on a daily basis
and first of all seeing the new york
city subways dessert in the middle of
the day is something very surreal uh
it's hard to describe as a lifelong new
yorker it's like being in a movie and
i'll never forget this moment i put on
my instagram this was a year ago
it takes a lot for me to get offended
and this was really one of those moments
there was an asian dude in his 30s you
know he was very western in his
appearance this wasn't someone who was
you know some kind of stereotypical
immigrant or something like that this
older man in his 50s white man stood
over him on the subway
literally screaming at him why aren't
you wearing a mask you're in america so
on and so forth just the most
base vulgar uh you know xenophobia and
that's a word i don't think i've ever
said before you know even thought about
and i realized wait a minute if you were
really scared of this virus which i can
understand why you would be why are you
getting physically close to him the
train car is quite large this guy's a
jerk he's you know in your in his
mindset okay he's a [ __ ] doesn't speak
english whatever stereotype you want to
describe to him get away from him but
clearly the guy felt empowered and
understandably so given the context of
the media and the culture to scream
and stand over in a very aggressive
manner and another human being so given
that
this is not an uncommon mindset and
we've seen it over and over where people
were proud of themselves uh to turn on
their neighbors and call the authorities
on them you know i had this tweet where
there was a huge reaction to it
and i stand by completely one of the
questions we always had in the west uh
and i'm sure everyone listening to this
has thought about at one point in their
life is how did you non-nazism happen
right were the germans uniquely evil uh
was this something where they just you
know everyone just like i gotta get
along or else i'm the next target
and what we saw
is that once enough of the kind of
decision makers create an outclass or an
enemy
very quickly everyone is champing at the
bit to kind of join in on them so all
these people on social media love to
think that they're the ones who would be
hiding anne frank in their attic but
what we've seen is they not only would
turn them in turn her in and her family
they would go on social media boasting
that they kind of turned in someone
who's the enemy and i'm doing the right
thing and i should receive accolades for
it and that kind of uh scary aspect of
the mindless malevolence which is so
common to the average person who is not
really a thinking being is something i
think more of us are increasingly coming
to grapple with now whether this is good
or bad i think is secondary i think once
you have data you have to accept it as a
given and make decisions accordingly as
opposed to thinking in some kind of
weird leninist way well we can just
remake these human beings and make them
something they're not
all the evidence i've seen is to the
contrary that these are roughly the
equivalent of barking dogs and if you
have barking dogs you have to deal with
them as barking dogs i'm not saying you
put them down but i'm saying all right
we've got a lot of dogs in this
neighborhood what are we going to do
about it
it's interesting because i i put a tweet
out exactly saying this very thing what
you've seen in the last 18 months is
which side of the barbed wire fence you
would have been on yes right great
metaphor um uh and and the thing is that
that is quite a scary realization so you
just think
this is what the mass of the people will
in this society at least and in your
society will will lean to in times of
crisis particularly pandemic we know
historically people become way more
quote conservative in times of of
disease uh and you but you at the same
time you've said i don't know whether he
was a throwaway commenter you mean you
mentored that you're writing a book
called the white pill
which you are uh in which you're gonna
express how optimistic you are about the
future yes but you but for many people
your version of optimism is a kind of
perverse optimism which is you are
optimistic about the breakdown of the
society we have because you expect a
better one to be available down the line
is that right
uh no that's that's not uh why i'm
optimistic i'm optimistic because this
book i don't want to spoil it too much
but uh when people
this is what i tell people i go when you
look at jeremy corbyn if you look at uh
you know nancy pelosi who's the house
speaker here or you look at the new york
times today or you know whoever your
villain of the moment is are they really
a more competent powerful threat than
hitler then stalin uh then the newspaper
people of you know 80 years ago when we
didn't have social media to call them
out on their malfeasance and depravity
so when you put it in those
when you look at these people who uh the
people who are on the side of the angels
which i certainly regard myself as being
are up against and to regard them as
unstoppable foes to me seems deranged i
mean
let me jump in though the thing is i i
where i i agree with you on that that's
absolutely the case in my opinion where
i disagree with you very strongly is
that we are up against those people i
don't think we are i think we're up
against the jack dorseys and the mark
zuckerbergs who who are
using the power that they have to shape
the way society is quote from susan
wojcicki who we absolutely love please
don't shadow banister yes exactly
i'm sorry but i i don't think jack
dorsey and mark zuckerberg even if they
were committed ideologues intent on
spreading their you know agit prop which
i don't think they are to the full
extent at all
are anything comparable
to you know the stalinist era and the cp
especially in britain uh it's it's i i
don't if you ask me what mark zuckerberg
or jack dorsey's politics are i neither
none of us know really fully i would
regard them as probably these kind of
you know left of center typical urban
you know elites but
at at worst these people are nothing in
terms of uh both their motivation and in
terms of their vision
of what a society should look like to be
what about the fact that they can take
down the president of the united states
and prevent him from speaking to the
people that he normally speaks to just
like that i'm not in favor of any
politician being allowed to speak so i
don't think
but but and that's the glib answer the
serious answer is they are not in a
position to completely censor the
president they're in a position to uh
censor him i don't i don't even like
using the word sensor here but they're
the position to block him from using
their mechanisms to speak
but there are there's no shortage of
alternative sources for him to have
immediately been able to get his message
out so even when they're doing their
best they can't do anything about it
meanwhile if you look at 70 years ago
their entire schools of thought which
were not only regard were completely
invisible but were regarded as heretical
and just nonsensical to even discuss so
i think that i i i'm not a utopian i
look at improvement and progress in a
context i think it's asymptotic but you
i think that's what people uh we have
kind of recency bias right so we look at
things and how they've been the last 10
years i'm taking the longer view and i
think if people do take that longer view
and compare things to how they were to
look at this look at the winter were
discontent in britain i mean in the 70s
you guys didn't have electricity uh i
mean it's just bizarre people don't
realize because we have it so good now
even during these lockdowns how bad it
was uh basically yesterday uh and we
forget about it because we weren't there
or because we're not living it and
that's just the 70s that's even talking
about the 40s and the 30s which were
just compared to today absolute
nightmare dystopias
and do you think part of your world view
michael is is informed by by your roots
as it were the fact that you probably
had parents grandparents telling you
about what it was like to live in the
soviet union so you have a point of
comparison i have the same constantin
has the same but the reality is for a
lot of people growing up in america or
the uk they don't understand that
because they that has never been
explained to them
someone should write a book about that
don't you think
yeah so stay tuned it'll be out within a
year
yeah that is that is so sorry that is
something that you as a as a fellow
countrymen appreciate the complete
naivete
of people in the west of just how bad it
can get you're from venezuela i mean
it's that's like the unspeakable horrors
that are going there we're just
completely oblivious to it uh there's
this american idea like
let's talk about the russian mindset
versus the american mindset right
i had a i have i pay a decent rent my
rent's pretty low it's below the market
because i'm a good tenant and i had an
issue with my sink um and every
american's like just go complain to your
landlord and make him fix it and i go
you don't like from the russian mindset
it's like okay if this cost him a
hundred dollars to fix he's just gonna
raise my rent by a hundred dollars so
now i'm out twelve hundred dollars for
the year instead of fixing it myself
this concept that authorities are
self-serving and
catching their attention is a bit like
the eye of sauron is something that in
the west maybe until last year it never
even entered their heads but as those of
us from eastern europe and from
venezuela appreciate
we do not have that perspective on
authority as you know neutral or
benevolent we you know inherently are
like all right i may have to pick up
this snake but i have to be aware that
it has teeth
yeah well it's funny you you mentioned
that you're writing a book about i'm
also writing a book called an
immigrant's love letter to the west
covering much of much of the same ground
um but we kind of hijacked you when you
were on the train of thought about uh
your optimism for the future and part of
that i i hear you if you take the long
view absolutely we live in better times
than we have in the past i i guess the
question i would have for you is
one of the things we also know from the
past is things can go from very good to
very bad quite quickly
and a lot of the conversations we've had
recently haven't exactly left us or our
audience with it with the sense of
optimism about the future so why are you
optimistic that things will get better
from here rather than a lot worse a lot
very quickly
sure so i think there's an increasing
amount certainly in america i can't
speak for britain although i would
suspect the case there where uh the
population by and large certainly the
ones who are kind of
intellectually curious have are just
completely tuning out the agile prop
coming out of corporate media and the
universities and the politicians it's no
longer it used to be even 10 years ago
some will put forth an issue
and then you spend time discussing the
pros and cons of the issue now
uh you increasingly especially with
since trump uh you'll have some
politician put forth an idea and it's
dead on arrival there's not even a
pretense that we're going to sit down
and have this discussion uh increasingly
people think that the other team
correctly is not engaged in good faith a
good issue on this is uh gun legislation
here in the states obviously we are much
more liberal in that subject in the
classic liberal sense than they are in
the uk
but for a long time it used to be all
right democrats will put forth uh
gun restrictions the conservatives will
argue about gun restrictions now
conservatives are increasingly
understanding okay this is just a
nonsense article argument there's no
such thing as an assault weapon ar-15
it's a standard weapon so our answer
isn't going to be to discuss things with
you we are going to put forth our bills
uh we are going to increase gun
proliferation which is the best answer
to gun control so at the end of the day
no matter what you guys are stamping
your feet about there's nothing you're
going to be able to do about it so that
kind of change in tactics to as opposed
to we're going to argue issue by issue
as now we're going to look at your
techniques disarm them and make sure you
can't use them in the future that is
very very healthy
ann coulter who's obviously a very
controversial figure who says things
very provocatively made a good point in
one of her books where she said if
you're a republican the new york times
isn't calling you racist you're losing
there have been school shootings in
america which is something that is just
unspeakably horrible and tragic and
whenever these things happen immediately
the next day you'll have politicians
trying to leverage this to argue for gun
control and this used to be for the gun
rights people something that would knock
them on their heels and there was a huge
media campaign after um there's a school
shooting in florida david hogg and all
these kids you know regarded as
propaganda figures we should listen to
the children because somehow they know
what they're talking about why don't why
they're in school i don't understand if
they're so wise just like greta dunberg
but that's a separate issue and there
was no
no i was shocked um back and forth on
the gun rights issue they're like yeah
we're not having this conversation and
this is when the bodies were still warm
so to have that kind of
change where you know they're not
engaged in good faith they're not
letting a tragedy go to waste we need to
take these people at face value that's
fallen away and that i think is a much
more effective strategy where you
understand all right there's always
going to be
a group
they could call themselves republican
they call us those democrat who are
interested in oppression and putting
forth their cockamamie schemes onto the
population and there's increasing people
who are like all right what mechanisms
can we put in place that whatever bs
they put forward in the future they're
not going to be able to do anything
about it here's another great example
there was a lot of hand wringing in 2016
about the american election putin putin
putin the russians the russians the
russians
it was not legitimate 2020 the day after
the election oh this was the most honest
election in history somehow trump in
four years went from being complete
corrupt to being a complete angel when
it comes to
uh uh democracy i don't know how they
manage to talk out of both sides of
their mouth but they don't care it's
whatever furthers their gender at the
moment increasingly uh because many of
these ballots were mailed in
which is open to fraud i'm not at all
claiming there was systematic fraud
different republican states are putting
mechanisms in place to restrict uh one's
ability to vote there's a oh my god this
is racism the
nazis and blah blah
but they're realizing you're going to be
called racist nazi clan regardless we
might as well change the rules so that
we win because we're paying the cost of
having these out this outrage and
insults and beratement we might as well
reap the benefits so that kind of
approach is i think a big sea change
from how things used to be
10 years ago and that is one big reason
for optimism a change in strategy for
those of us who are in favor of freedom
which i do not regard as synonymous
democracy of course and opposed to uh
you know what manchester small bug calls
the cathedral
but michael let me push back on that
somewhat because isn't debating ideas
the very foundation of our society and
by debating ideas don't you find that
actually you find where the strengths
are to your argument you find out where
the weaknesses are and you find actually
you truly find what out what you think
because you have your ideas challenged
and the second part of the pushback is
the weapons that you use
against your opponents will invariably
you be used against you when they are in
power
yeah sure so first of all i don't think
the base of a society a good idea is in
the basis of a good society is peace and
i think the biggest threat to peace is
the state uh it is only the state that
can wage murder in a systematic way it
is only the state that can reach theft
in a systematic way both through theft
and some taxation excuse me and
something called asset forfeiture i
don't know if you have that over there
over here we have something called asset
forfeiture which is a very bizarre
legal system which is if i'm a police
officer and i believe that you used your
car your house your bank account in
furtherance of the drug trade i can
seize it it is added to my budget and
then you have to go through a whole
legal process
although you don't have any money or a
car anymore to try to get it back and as
a result of this the total of asset
forfeiture has now in america surpassed
the total of all burglaries combined so
that sort of thing is something that has
to change immediately
i'm not interested in having the right
ideas or the wrong ideas that is
secondary to me in terms of putting food
in the table being secure in my person
you know all these other things it's i'm
i'm perfectly happy being wrong as long
as i have like maslow's hierarchy of
needs uh being met there's lots of
people who have disparate ideas in every
country by definition many of them are
going to be wrong i still want them to
have food and i still want them to be
secure in their property the person and
their families that is much more primary
than having the right ideas well i'm
sorry
in terms of the tactics yeah it is my
view
that the enemy class will use
any tactics in its capacity up to and
including mass murder and once you
realize this is what you're up against
you have to start fighting back so i do
not agree for one second uh that the
villains in in either of our respective
countries the only thing that is
restraining them is their inability or
they're not having a need at the moment
to put these um tactics into practice
but in terms of them like kind of oh
should we really do this i don't think
that's a concern in their part at all
they genuinely if you watch those
footage from belgium
where there were people sitting in a
public park and police on horseback were
clubbing old men in the face because
they're outside in a park uh i don't
think you can put anything past these
people
aren't there was talk wasn't there talk
in britain of going door to door uh to
make sure people were staying home or
being vaccinated there was talk of that
here it's just i i don't see how you
could put anything past these people so
michael i want to ask you actually a
question a a longer question but the
short question is who are they
sure so it's the power structure it's
the ruling class
so
who is that exactly sure it would be the
universities so how it's the ideas start
the universities which are literal
monasteries of the progressive faith uh
they're promulgated and turned into kind
of sleeper cells or
um shock troops via the media and
entertainment industries where a certain
mindset is regarded as not as
true and just a given
and then it's promulgated further
through government schools and public
school teachers uh and then it's
implemented if necessary by the state
via the police
hey francis think about all the times
you've used wi-fi at a coffee shop or
hotel or even at your parents house
happy memories well without expressvpn
every site you visit could be locked by
the admin of that network and that's
still true even when you're in cognitive
mode even when you're in cognitive mode
still happy memories what what's more
your home internet provider i'm talking
comcast at t whatever can also see and
record your browsing data and they're
legally allowed to sell it on to others
i'm so screwed you are trigonometry is
now going to be a solo project and that
is why i use expressvpn expressvpn is an
app that encrypts all of your network
data and re-routes it through a network
of secure servers so that your private
online activity stays just that
private
unfortunately so
sadly every site you visit every video
you watch or message you send gets
tracked and data mined but when you run
expressvpn on your device the software
hides your ip address so expressvpn
makes your activity harder to trace and
sell to advertisers finish absolutely
done for and the best part is how easy
it is to use the app literally has one
button you tap it to connect and your
browsing activities secure from your
parents eyes for answers please stop
crying my new suede shoes are getting
wet if you don't want to end up like me
and stop your parents from protecting
your privacy go to expressvpn.com
trigger and get three extra months for
free
e x p r e s s v p n dot com slash
trigger go to expressvpn.com
trigger to learn more
so
coming back then to to what you were
saying about your reasons for optimism
which is if i can translate it correctly
and do correct me if i get it wrong is
the left can i say that the left has
been using uh certain tactics against
the right which is calling them names is
that you you're you're from i don't like
that expression the left right because
there are many people who we would all
agree are on the left who are amazing
human beings who maybe i disagree with
an issue or that but who would be first
and foremost to be fighting these things
so i don't think this is a very kind of
boomer conservative mindset which i'm
not saying you guys hold no the left is
a monolith which is just historically
and worldwide just
right so
so yeah exactly and it's always a
struggle when when talking about these
issues because you're trying to speak to
to the way the conversation is being had
at the moment so
that side are they progressives who is
it that's been using these tactics of
calling everyone names and sure so with
britain i i mean if it was just down to
names we'd be in a utopia right can you
imagine this is my goal my goal is to
have a free society where the worst
thing someone can do is go up to you and
call you the most horrible epithets
which is basically what i do on a daily
basis on twitter if that's the case
right and the worst thing someone can do
is you know insult my mother and call me
just just just a garbage person
they might be right
but at least we're living peacefully and
civilly and no one has to worry about uh
a knock on the door and uh the filth
barging in so
what i specifically referred to in my
previous book than you write is
evangelical progressive evangelical
evangelical progressivism i'm scared to
say it because i'm going to invoke the
eye of sauron
and it's basically a totalitarian
worldview
intent on
conquering every aspect of society which
does not regard as anything outside its
purview
and i'll give you a good example if you
look at
i talk about this and then you write as
well if you look at video games if you
look at sci-fi movies right
even places people go to escape reality
other planets other dimensions back in
time is not safe to be outside their
purview they genuinely feel that every
aspect of our culture including our
bedroom is something where they are in a
position to not only opine which i can
understand that
you can make the case for that
everything should be up for discussion
but to impose
their perspective on how to live if this
is what you are up against you know this
kind of absolutist universalist
totalitarian mindset there is very
little room for negotiation and you have
to create tactic you're not going to
show a creationist fossils and disprove
their worldview they're just going to
take whatever evidence they see as
furtherance of their perspective right i
agree with that so maybe aggressive
locust is is a better way to to
summarize i don't know if you i don't
like calling it and here's why because
in britain at least it has its roots in
the fabian society which started in the
late 1800s and for those who don't know
their
mascot was literally
look this up because it sounds like
something a crazy person is saying
a wolf in sheep's clothing because their
argument is all right we can't have a
totalitarian dictatorship voted
overnight but
what we can do is death by a million
cuts little by little we implement these
ideas and by the time we're done we're
going to have everything within the
context of the state later
they will realize you know maybe if
we're calling ourselves a wolf and sheep
clothing we're showing our hands so they
change their mascot to a turtle or a
tortoise rather um
but that these people are playing the
long game they have for a hundred years
uh they've been after everyone's
children for over a century the whole
point of government schooling is in
their words to create good citizens
which is a euphemism for breaking young
independent minds uh banishing critical
thought from their uh psyche and making
them malleable subservient and
interchangeable with everyone else they
got the idea from bismarck and the
prussian model where his idea was okay
let's take schools and basically create
an army starting from age five
kindergarten there's a reason why it's a
german word so i think when people
realize how long this has been going on
and how systemic and deep these roots go
uh there's going to be a lot of
epiphanies in terms of what the
consequences of this have been all right
so uh these evangelical progressives as
you call them uh
that i was just coming back to the
question that i'm still desperately
trying to ask uh but i appreciate the
clarifications because they are
important uh they
have been using these tactics against
the rest of society or whoever it is
that they they they're targeting them
out and now you are optimistic because
some of the people who are
in terms of the examples that you gave
in america identifiably on the right the
people who care about uh gun rights etc
etc
they are now fighting back
and ignoring the tactics and not then
essentially not complicit in their own
demonization anymore right they're
refusing to play along in the stupid
game right
the end now if i play that movie forward
there's two ways that ends and i know
you're a big advocate for one of them uh
either you get a civil war or you get a
peaceful separation of the united states
into red states and blue states exactly
that's that's a medium-term goal yes i
mean and this claim this is it's a so
one of the lies we hear here in the
states is that any kind of national
separation has to be done violently
and they're like can you give me one
example of a country where a loud
secession it's like yeah czechoslovakia
brexit norway and sweden these were all
done very peacefully and everyone lived
happily ever after as a result brexit of
course was not a smooth transition but
it was hardly you know violent uh or you
know a civilian a lot of milkshakes got
thrown man a lot of milkshakes went
flying a little bit epithets were held
on twitter yeah yeah so but i mean yeah
yeah
but i mean the joke is important because
one of the techniques they use is look
as bad as thing if i had the choice
between the status quo
and another american civil war i would
probably choose the status quo because
this a civil war was just a complete
nightmare situation the loss of life and
property and and recovery was
unconscionable so it behooves them
you know it's the kind of like you don't
want your battered wife to leave it's
like maybe you're not going to find
anyone else who's going to love you as
much as i do and at a certain point you
realize oh this is a lie
they're saying this because they realize
i do have other options and they have to
persuade me to stay because they have to
paint the alternative as full of just
blood and destruction and when you
realize realize that there's plenty of
contemporary counter examples and
you know who's gonna do what who has the
will to do this it becomes very clear
which option is preferable i'll ask a
final question in this line of
discussion because this is interesting
to explore intellectually if nothing
else there seems to me the obvious
contradiction in your argument is that
you've got these uh people that you
refer to who will use any means
including up to and including mass
murder and at the same time you think
they will let half the united states go
peacefully if it so chooses that doesn't
seem to square to me
so al-qaeda is a good example al-qaeda
would have no problem committing mass
murder they just don't have the power to
do so so at a certain point it becomes a
matter of do they have the will do they
have the capacity uh and i
and the more people are becoming aware
that this is a situation the harder it's
going to be to pull off their uh uh
bullcrap you had
in the american civil war you know
they fi there was it was not at all
inevitable uh what happened was the
south had something called fort sumter
which was the north considered northern
property they had it barricaded and then
they fired a shot we wouldn't have been
in world war ii rightly or wrongly and
i'm not at all implying that it was the
wrong thing to do without the attack on
pearl harbor right previously to pearl
harbor this is a european war we just
did that with woodrow wilson the great
war why are we killing ourselves or for
them again we just went through this
this was a complete calamity then
there's a strike and it's like all arms
uh on deck so it's not at all inevitable
that there would be a
violence at all or that if there was
violence it would necessarily lead to a
large scale it could be very the civil
war for example is is a good example
when there when it first started the the
south the confederates who are i do not
at all regard as the heroes let me be
clear had an opportunity to seize
washington take over the white house and
hold lincoln captive they were so
invested in their ideology of national
sovereignty that they felt okay if we
cross this line across this rubicon
we're going to be hypocrites so they
didn't do it if they had done it and
kind of been a little bit hypocritical
the war could have been resolved very
very quickly so it's not at all the case
that if there is a conflict that it has
to be that long or that and
even if they win look at it this way
let's suppose there's like a hundred
thousand people who agree with me who
want separation if they're put down with
great force which i i'm terrified to
imagine that still wouldn't have to take
five years it could be resolved very
quickly so it's it's all a matter of
willpower uh um
and and that i think there's a
decreasing amount uh on behalf of some
of these people certainly among the
masses
so michael the question i want to ask is
what part do the corporations play in
this because there's many people who
argue the corporations are now far more
powerful than any government we can see
this with regard to taxation they
essentially do what they want how they
want whenever they want
they don't do what they want however
they want because they can't come in
your house and kill you one of the
tweets i had which i certainly think is
that corporate america has done a far
better job of
spreading maoism than the chinese
communist party ever dreamed of in the
states so
when the riots were happening here i
tweeted out that they're about 48 hours
from getting corporate sponsorship it
was within minutes when that ended up
happening but i mean
you you laugh but growing up we were all
taught that corporations are basically
like mild republicans they're kind of
yeah the fat guy with the cigar whoever
pops out to the golf course or like mitt
romney you know or like um um david
cameron right like that's the
corporations it's this kind of vaguely
right of center doesn't want to ruffle
feathers you know just wants business
and everyone to get along and it's kind
of this milk toast mindset what we're
seeing instead is given that
corporations are almost exclusively
manned by people who are the products of
these universities these which are
spreading these uh depraved malevolent
ideas once they're in place this is
gramsci's march through the institutions
then they are going to without having to
have anyone in their earpiece um
organically spreading this kind of
ideology and philosophy now does that
mean we have to raise harvard to the
ground
no does that mean
does that mean it would probably be a
net benefit yes
wow so you think that because
surely that we can reform institutions
can we not michael or create
alternatives or create alternatives at
the very least this is the one
okay go for it explain why we create
alternatives
and how and not reform institutions
i think some institutions are inherently
um irredeemable and i think it's also
useful in terms of morale to watch them
uh raised and burned to the ground
because that's a concrete victory that
people who are less intelligent can
point to and regard as
an accomplishment
in a very evil sense if you look at 9 11
that must have been incredibly
motivating for the terrorist class the
middle east because we're north korea
that's the book i wrote obviously dear
reader what they often talk about is
we're a shrimp among whales that we're a
tiny country and yet we're giving the
finger uh both to
china and to the united states and from
their perspective there's something to
that you know they're punching way above
their weight class so i think um
many institutions are inherently evil
uh they've been evil for a very long
time uh their complicity in things like
uh the ukrainian genocide uh you know
hitler a stalin is something they've
never had accountability for and i'm not
interested in accepting their apologies
uh this many years after the fact for
what they've done i'm interesting in
watching them uh be destroyed and suffer
in the process
and how do you mind that
mindset coming through yes
i can i can feel that yeah but
we talked about creating alternative
institutions
how do you do that sure
i mean how does anyone create anything
you have i have an idea i get capital i
put my shingle up and then i attract
people to uh um
my venue uh creating alternatives to
universities is going to be increasingly
easy because for example i had a fan who
um
we're gonna i'm gonna show all of our
age now he sent me a contribution he
said oh can i interview for my school
paper i looked at his twitter the kids
in high school i'm like kid i'm not
taking money from you and he goes no no
i have a hundred grand in the bank i do
e-commerce right so it's very hard
to tell this person you should go to
university for four years and if i'm an
interviewer a recruiter and i have two
resumes this person went to cambridge
and this kid in high school is making a
hundred grand a year because he invented
a website who would i want to hire now
the harvard guy is going to or the
cambridge guy excuse me is going to have
technical knowledge and he's going to
have a lot bring lots of tables no
question but in terms of being
competitive it is not at all clear to me
or i don't think to anyone that it's
clearly the cambridge guy who you want
to choose from as opposed to let's
suppose 40 years ago it would have been
absolutely clear where okay this kid
some young entrepreneur who made some
butcher shop this guy went to cambridge
you know if i'm playing roulette i'm
putting my money on cambridge
there we go i mean michael it has been
an absolutely fascinating interview
thank you so much for coming on the show
we've got a couple of questions for our
local supporters after this but our
interviews always end with the same
question which is what's the one thing
we're not talking about but we really
should be
um
that's a great question i'm not a big
should
person
but i think what the issue that i think
is the least discussed is the
increasing inability in european
parliaments which is going to spread to
the states to form coalitions
you saw it in the swedish elections you
saw in the italian elections on the
czech elections um increasingly we used
to
you're seeing in germany now where the
elections are going to be september and
for the first time in german history
they're going to have to
almost certainly have a three-party
coalition whereas historically it's
always been one and then under merkel
she's had to have a coalition with the
social democrats this inability to form
a majority
uh well iceland's another example a
majority in terms of putting forth the
state's vision i think is a very healthy
thing to the breakdown of having a
government monopoly
oh you're true true to the cause all the
way to the bit around michael listen
it's been a pleasure chatting with you
uh i recommend everybody get all your
books the new right i particularly
enjoyed and uh the anarchist handbook is
that is that the one that's the last one
anarchisthandbook.com yes fantastic
stuff uh thank you for coming on the
show and thank you all for watching at
home we'll see you very soon with
another brilliant interview like this
one or raw show and they always go out 7
p.m uk time 2 p.m eastern eastern
standard time take care and see you soon
guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below